i am nick gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Veronique de
Russia she's a reason columnist and an
economist for the Mercatus Center at
George Mason University frequent
collaborator with me Veronique thanks
for coming thanks for having me we want
to talk about austerity there is a
growing backlash against austerity
measures in governments especially in
Europe you have people like Larry
Summers you have people like Paul
Krugman saying look Europe has tried
estera t measures and their economies
are tanking they're going down like the
Titanic what is being talked about when
people say that austerity has been tried
in Europe what these guys are saying is
that the reason why Europe is doing very
poorly is because they've tried to cut
spending dramatically right but really
when you actually look at what happened
in Europe they've tried what's here we
call the balanced approach which is like
a mix of spending cuts and tax increase
when I think of austerity what I figure
as the government is just saying you
know what we spent a billion dollars
this year we're spending 500 million
next year that's not what's happening in
Europe well that's not even what how
most people will describe austerity what
they their goal is and that's how like
most budgets are even written is there
set targets for reducing the debt to GDP
ratio and you can do it in many ways you
can you know cut spending but you can
also do a mix of spending cuts tax
increases or just tax increases Krugman
in particular has looked at England and
said you know what they tried austerity
the camera government was talking about
cutting spending and luck their economy
they're gone back in recession what's
wrong with that analysis well first I
mean when Krugman talks about austerity
in the UK or in Europe in general he
implies that it's only spending cuts
that were put in place he never ever
talk about the tax increases which were
quite substantial also he talks about
what Cameron has actually said he was
going to do not what has really been
done and what Cameron it's true its
proposed to do was he was going to
dramatically cut spending it was going
to be something like
nineteen percent across the board for
each departments he was going to engage
in serious pension reforms he was going
to reduce taxes the reality when you
look at the data is actually spending
his gun up I mean it hasn't grown as
fast as it used to but it still has gone
up England and the rest of Europe is a
good example of what the balanced
approach is when you look at these guys
austerity measures when you look at
charts that they produce it is really
almost a quelle amount of spending cuts
and tax increases they're going to close
deficits and reduce that to gdp by they
say they're going to cut spending a
little bit and they're going to raise
taxes they're going to cut spending and
they often have very ambitious spending
cuts in mind and they're going to raise
taxes but what ends up happening is this
the tax increases are real but then in
most cases the spending cuts don't
materialize in cameron's cases for
instance he had talked about reforming
pensions to be concrete well two years
later they still has been no no reform
of pensions because people have been you
know interest great in interest groups
were not on board and so he's not pushed
it through so you also in your work
you've referenced economic research that
looks at past successful cases where
countries were able to reduce the debt
to GDP ratio and they issue a balanced
approach what what do they use and
what's the effect of that on you know
whether or not a country goes into
recession or not so there's a series of
economics who have actually looked at
this at this question is like what type
of austerity works or doesn't work and
for instance alberto alesina at harvard
and Sylvia are Daria they've looked at
107 attempts to reduce debt to GDP ratio
in in all the countries in the OECD over
the last 30 years right and what they
found is at the successful debt
reduction package of fiscal adjustment
package were the one that were made
exclusively of spending cuts what
they've shown is that the balanced
approach to basically the country that
have tried to reduce that to GDP ratio
by doing a mix of spending cuts and tax
increases have fell may be more relevant
also is the fact that they've shown that
packages that were made of spending cuts
they were actually more likely to lead
to an expansion to economic growth while
the one that were made well when you try
to actually stimulate the economy
through spending you were less likely to
get an expansion people always when they
look to Europe they never see you know
they always talk about Greece they was
talking about Italy they typically talk
about countries that have had flagging
economies for a very long time they
never talked about Germany which you
know is the leading economy in Europe
really in terms of energy and activity
what is Germany doing that the rest of
the world or at least the rest of Europe
should be thinking about emulating
Germany is actually an example for
America because Germany is by many
accounts now doing better than us they
have a six point two percent
unemployment rate what they've done is
that in two in 2004 they've actually
engaged in serious structural reform
because it's another thing that
economists have found when they looked
at what kind of you know fiscal
adjustment packages work and they found
that structural reforms were and by that
you mean it's not just saying okay we're
cutting 10% next year it's that we're
changing spending patterns that
governments are locked into but not that
only it's also labor labor market
reforms think about it I mean labor
market laws I mean direct how easily is
going to be to get a job start a
business fire someone who doesn't work
but also the type of benefits that
people who are unemployed are going to
get right and so what German what
Germany is done in 2004 I think it was
if they dramatically reform their labor
market so that's what they call the mini
jobs you know those jobs that are not
necessarily very lucrative are easily to
get by to get that you can go in and out
of the workforce more and also that
there's much fewer incentives to stay
unemployed so they've reduced the the
the unemployment benefits and they've
done the second thing that is very
important is that they've reduced the
size and pay of government employees
well thank you very much for talking to
reason TV about austerity and its
discontents for reason TV I'm nickel SP